[Music]
foreign
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the table
on this sunday evening where the sun is
shining
spring is in the air uh
my name is karen miner by the way i'm
part of the leadership team here at the
table welcome welcome
so glad you're here um i was just
thinking back to the last time i did
announcements it was
literally snowing outside and really
really cold
what a difference a couple weeks makes
um
but uh yeah just really glad you're here
i hope you've been able to get outside
and take advantage of the sunshine and
the mild weather especially after
snowpocalypse
and i was also thinking too gosh you
know it's been
it's been a full year since we've been
doing online services and since
everything
really shut down in our area due to
covid it's been
a full year and a lot has happened a lot
has changed in our world and in our
community
um and i was also thinking that
on this day back in 1965 which sounds
like a long time ago but
really it was only seven years before i
was born
um but that's when uh
the march um across the edmund pettus
bridge
and bloody sunday happened where um
people were marching across the bridge
to start the selma
montgomery march for voting rights and
they were
met very very violently by state
troopers
um in alabama and
just how um you know it
so much has changed since then a lot
hasn't changed since then
um but really what brought me to that
was
that verse in hebrews i believe it's
hebrews 12 that talks about the great
cloud of witnesses
that we're surrounded by and the verse
says since we are surrounded by such
a great cloud of witnesses let us throw
off
everything that hinders us and the sin
that so easily entangles us
and let us run with perseverance the
race marked out for us
and i was thinking that you know a year
ago
i know i didn't have any idea that we
would still be here
in varying levels of quarantine um and
all of the restrictions of covid
um you know a year later
and i'm guessing many of you didn't
either but the truth is we're still here
like we there are many that are not um
unfortunately
um but we are still here and
um there are many heroes and witnesses
among us
that you won't read about in headlines
or in history books
but who are just as heroic just as
faithful
who've shown just as much perseverance
and courage
as those that that people will read
about decades from now
and it just was a good reminder that
um there's something to be said for
those who persevere faithfully even in
the midst of
hardship and trouble and challenge and
um who put their faith
and hope in god who doesn't guarantee
that we're gonna have a harm-free life
or a hurt free life but who says you
will not walk that out alone
and i think one of the things as i look
back on the past year that i'm so so
grateful for
is this community and the steadfastness
of it of showing up every week without
fail and saying
we're going to gather together and most
of the time we don't know what we're
doing
um but we just want to be together and
we want to center on jesus
and we do that with hope that that
we bring the little that we have and god
is here with us
meets with us and takes our little and
turns it into transformation and healing
and growth
and just those really really important
reminders that we're never alone
there are always brighter days ahead and
that god is always there with us
so um that was encouraging to me
in the midst of everything going on and
it's really cool right now to see
those signs of spraying and signs of new
life
and it just feels like the perfect
metaphor for
what we're what we're going through and
what we're experiencing as we head
from quarantine into hopefully in the
next few
months coming out of that more and more
and please god let it be true
so anyways in that vein i wanted to
share with you a couple of announcements
and they are um things to keep on your
radar
save the dates so the first one is it's
been a long time since we've been able
to
do an outreach event at the table
but our first one is a really really
good one and it's going to be
with the five loaves food pantry which
is located in saxi
so it's our neighborhood food bank
they're amazing you guys they've been
doing
amazing amazing work throughout this
pandemic talk about heroes
and one of those that i count as
being in the cloud of witnesses like
they've been doing such good work
and we have the opportunity to help them
out by packing up some food
for families and people in need in our
community so mark
the date we're going to be doing this on
friday
march 26th at 5 00 p.m
be looking for a sign up genius if
you're available and interested
you'll be able to sign up for that um
secondly easter is coming uh easter is
sunday april 4th
that'll be here before we know it and we
are planning to do an outdoor
morning service uh at a location to be
announced a little later
um but please mark your calendars for
that we will let you know the time and
location as soon as that's set but we
would love to have you join us
outdoors for a beautiful easter service
on the 4th and then the following sunday
on april 11th we are dramaal
please we are going to
gather in person for the first time in
over a year so it's kind of a big deal
uh we're going to do that at pleasant
valley new methodist church um
back in our old stomping grounds and um
so we're planning to do that on april
11th as long as you know
cases continue to come down and all that
good stuff we're continuing to monitor
that
but we are hopeful that we'll be able to
do that on april 11th
and um all of that information is going
to be
coming out via email all of the details
so you want to make sure you're on our
email list
if you're not our wonderful host tonight
marissa is going to post that
information
i think she's going to post brett's
email address so if you are not on our
email addre
email distribution list and you have not
been getting our emails
make sure you shoot a message to brett
and get on that email list and that way
uh you'll be able to get all the
information we're gonna do sign
ups just to make sure we're keeping
within capacity keeping things safe for
people that do want to join we'll be
having a live stream as well for those
of you that are not yet
doing things in person so um i really
hope you'll be able to join us
for that so how about with that
as we transition into our musical
worship
let's take a moment to center on jesus
still our hearts and our minds
and just take time together in prayer
god thank you so much for today and all
the ways that you're in it
thank you for your creation and for
nature that
shows us again and again how you
are in the business of renewal and
transformation
and growth
and that you never leave us where we are
and that you can be trusted with that
good work god
we thank you for the past year
as we reflect back um just the highs and
the lows
god thank you that you've been in it
with us thank you that we
are still together we're still here um
and that's a big deal so god i thank you
for this community
and i thank you for those that are
tuning in tonight i pray
your blessing over each and every one of
them very personally god
and i thank you for your goodness your
faithfulness help our
minds to be open our ears to be open for
what you have for us tonight god
help our lives to be surrendered to you
fully
and to take that next step that you have
for each one of us
towards you in jesus name
amen
hey you guys hey it's been in now
in the morning community
reference for those of you who watch it
hey um
so as we're gonna worship together this
evening um
we picked some songs that are referring
to
jesus as our light and i hope that
as you're listening tonight and
worshiping with us that you experience
this sense of
peace this sense of
this ability to be still and to know
that god is here that he is for you that
his grace and his goodness are enough
um yeah he
[Music]
yeah i just is that we get these
opportunities these pockets together
especially when we're singing and making
space for like creative music and
worship
[Music]
um
enjoy what god the ways that he meets us
in these moments together so you guys
join in with us
and peace bring it all the peace
the storm surrounding me let it break
[Music]
is jesus jesus
you make the darkness tremble jesus
jesus your silence fear oh
jesus
you make the darkness tremble jesus
breathe call
once
[Music]
you make again darkness triple jesus
jesus you silence
fear on jesus jesus
you make the darkness jesus
[Music]
jesus
and your name is a light
that the shadows can't deny
your name cannot be overcome
[Music]
sing that with us your name
is alive that the shadows can't deny
your name cannot be overcome yes lord
[Music]
jesus jesus
you made the darkness triple jesus jesus
your silence fear oh jesus
jesus
[Music]
your glory is so beautiful
i fall
and the heartbeat of my life
is to worship in your light
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
is
you made this
[Music]
your glory is so beautiful
is
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus
[Music]
you are
you are good
your name is light
that the shadows can't deny
and your name cannot be
overcome
[Music]
is
is to worship in your life
[Music]
just
to rest upon
his promise
[Music]
jesus jesus
precious jesus
[Music]
god i believe we can trust you that you
really are a good guy
that you really are for us
that you see beauty god in who
we are
that you're the one that calls us away
from shame
and into grace that you're the one who
brings light to our darkness
[Music]
we experience those pockets of your
glory
and the way that we love each other and
the way that we care for one another
i see your glory in the faces that sit
around this table
god when someone brings a meal
to somebody whenever they're having a
hard week when someone calls or reaches
out
and encourages one another
[Music]
god where there's care where there's
compassion
where there's a heart for justice and
love god i see your glory there
would we continue to create those
pockets
where glory can come and rest on us
would we continue
to bring your light into the darkness
to pursue it to make space for it
god to seek it out would we find you
in all the little pieces of our lives
and in one another we love you so much
and thanks for this time together amen
amen thank you mindy and melody
and uh before them karen
well good evening everyone grace and
peace
welcome to the table it's uh great to be
with all of you
and we are in part three in our series
uh titled lent from repentance to
renewal
and uh the season of lent in the
christian calendar is
a time of basically spiritual
preparation leading
up to good friday and that of course is
the day where we remember jesus
crucifixion
so you know many people in our community
right now are either fasting something
that is giving something up or they are
engaging a
a new spiritual practice or discipline
and so if you haven't already it's not
you know it's not too late we're really
just
just a few weeks into lent so you're
welcome to uh join us
in this this season of preparation so
with that in mind the title of my
message
this evening is return
return our primary texts are going to be
ephesians chapter 2
verses 1 through 5 and isaiah chapter 30
verse 15
and uh the great brock ellison
uh none of you may recognize him um he
was at our
christmas eve uh service if i remember
or maybe
i can't remember but um
brock's a good guy so he's he's pretty
new to the community the last few
months maybe six months now so you know
only online um but i hope you get to
know him
and get a little insight into his
personality during this reading
so brock take it away
hey everybody like about mention my name
is brock
and i'll be reading the passages for
today the first one comes from
ephesians 2 verses 1 through 5
in the inner and this is from the niv as
for you
you were dead in your transgressions and
sins in which you used to live
when you followed the ways of this world
and of the ruler of the kingdom of the
air
the spirit who is now at work in those
who are disobedient
all of us lived among them at one time
gratifying the cravings of our flesh
and following its desires and thoughts
like the rest
we were by nature deserving of wrath
but because of his great love for us god
his rich and mercy made us alive with
christ
even when we were dead in transgressions
it is by grace you have been saved
the second one is isaiah 30
verses 15 and this is from the nlt
this is what the sovereign lord the holy
one of israel says
only in returning to me and resting in
me
will you be saved in quietness and
confidence
is your strength but you would have none
of it
thank you brock so a few weeks ago
in my weekly e-letter i
linked out to a story on espn.com
and as much as i love sports i think
this was my first ever link to espn
it's just you know it's not exactly
known for its profound
depth and analysis of the human
condition
but i i came across this article about
former new york yankees pitcher cc
sabathia and his incredibly arduous
journey
from alcoholism to sobriety
and the article's purpose was to kind of
spread the word about a documentary
sabathia put out uh titled under the
grapefruit tree that's uh currently on
hbo max
though i haven't actually seen that i've
only read this article
um so i won't like give everything away
um in case you end up wanting to watch
that but but basically the very short
version is in 2015
uh cc made the very difficult decision
to leave the yankees um
right before the playoffs started
because he was
deep in the throes of a struggle with
alcohol
and uh and of course i mean the timing
of it was
very controversial um if you're a
yankees fan you might you know remember
this
because you know a lot of the fans are
thinking like i mean you played the
whole season
couldn't you just put this off another
eight weeks until
this kind of playoff run ends like why
right now
and then you know get your life right
but uh but no no
ccm he knew he needed help
and um what i found that was so
compelling about this article
is is that espn they chose the
absolute perfect writer for this
piece that his name is ryan hawkensmith
and just a few years prior he
um had battled a prescription pain
uh medication and alcohol addiction and
that um basically it took him to to some
very
very dark places and so what hawkinsmith
does
is he weaves his own story
with sabathias and y'all it is a
spirit inspired article um
it's it's amazing you go back to my
e-letter and find that or if you want i
can send it to you
um but here's just this is just one
paragraph
that really i mean it just gripped me so
this is hawkinsmith writing and this is
at this point he's talking about his own
journey he's not talking about um
sabathia at this point
uh so hawkins smith he writes this
that's the thing
about what drugs and alcohol
did to me for me actually
they made me not have to be present
they helped me not be here
i could go over there in
here i had to feel stuff
to know i was a bad husband
and an unreliable worker and a flaky
brother in here the mortgage was overdue
and my daughter was teething and my
right front tire was leaking
air here was real life
the hard stuff i couldn't handle here
but over there over there that difficult
big boy crap got swept away a daily
solution of
pills and booze a near-death experience
that wiped my hard drive clean every
night i could try to deal with here
again tomorrow
maybe it'll be better in the morning
of course this i mean this is not just
ryan hawkins smith's story and it's
not in a way sabathia's story um this is
our story and
our story it may not be quite as
dramatic um
it may not be black out drunk every
night
uh but who doesn't relate to that
feeling
of not wanting to face our life
of wanting to run away i i
so appreciated how both almost like
intense and mundane um the things were
that uh that he kind of named like on
the more intense side
it's you know it's the realization i
can't face that i'm a
bad husband i'm a bad brother
um but also he names how it's it was the
mundane
right it was the day in day out slowly
wear you
down type of things the the mortgage is
overdue the baby is teething
the kids are crying the i thought the
best one though
my right front tire is leaking air
so that's so perfect like what drove me
to drink my right front tire was leaking
air
i mean why because it's it's just this
sense of overwhelm like you just the
things start to pile up and it's like i
i i don't want to be i don't want to be
here
you know like what what led me to engage
xyz destructive behavior
my kids kept crying like this is what
he's naming so powerfully
is that there's a certain almost a
restlessness
that animates our lives we're we're just
so restless our minds are so
restless there's just no peace it's this
constant
um well i mean how did ephesians 2 verse
3 put it paul says
all of us also lived among them at one
time
gratifying the cravings of our flesh
and following its desires in thoughts
that word craving that is the perfect
word
uh later he uses the word desire uh but
you know we often think well desire me
that can be that's can be good you know
i desire to serve people i desire to
love god
like okay well obviously paul's not
talking about desire in that sense
instead he's talking about
what ryan hawkensmith is talking about
that that impulsive
desire that that craving for things
to help me escape we want we want to
escape our feelings escape
our anxiety escape our fear
escape our self-loathing it's this
restless craving our minds they're
they're almost like a
like a dog you know chasing a scent
just kind of just just
just all day just every day like there's
there's there's something else there's
there's something
something i'm missing is we kind of go
over here like i'm just i'm not
satisfied with where i am there's
something
there's something i'm missing just
searching searching searching searching
searching
and and sometimes um we kind of hit the
jackpot and we kind of we satisfy our
craving
like for an hour or maybe a day
um rarely a day i mean it
just it almost never lasts and then
we're right back to it
that restless craving
and of course i mean christianity is not
alone in this diagnosis
of the human roots of sin going back to
this
um kind of endless search for
you know pleasure um it's very similar
to
to what the the zen buddhist folks would
call craving and aversion
here's a very um simple definition for
these craving
is the idea um you know if i had that
then i would be happy that's basically
craving like it's the dog sniff
it's the pursuit it's the you know i
don't want to be here i need the thing
over there
if i had that if i could get there then
i would be happy so that's craving
an aversion is basically kind of the
inverse
if i could avoid that
then i would be happy right so craving
if i had that then i'd be happy
aversion if i could avoid that then i
would be
happy and uh and so this is our lives
like it's basically just screaming
anniversary we're just sort of making
our way through the world
um and and this is why often our our
kind of sense of joy
and happiness is so fleeting because the
cravings
just uh they never satisfy never it
never
leads to a sense of long-term peace
and the aversions the right front tire
leaking air
i mean the things we don't want to
happen uh well they just keep right on
happening
and and yet paul says in ephesians 2
verse 3
all of us also lived among them at
one time in other words that used to be
the path we were on
paul's saying like we were all in our
own ways
cc sabathia we were all in our own ways
ryan hawkins smith chasing our
never-ending desires
trying to escape our pain trying to find
peace by satisfying our cravings it's
it's the way of the world and and paul
is saying like
that used to be us we we all know what
it's like
to live there uh i i think if
paul were live today he might say um
you know we used to be the people
who believe the commercials the glossy
advertisements that used to be us you
remember when you were young
and a long time ago for some of you
joke all right remember when you're
young and you um
you believed the advertisements
like believing that your cravings could
be satisfied believing
that if um if only you took that pill
or worked out in just that right way
then you could avoid
all of the bad things in the world um
or if you just got that new thing like
then that would be it i i see this so
much with my
kids um they're 11 9 and 6 so you know
they're like in that
that range where they like see
something random usually on youtube like
a super soaker commercial
and suddenly it's their their passion
for living
you know they're like dad oh and they'll
show me like the running with the ipad
like oh my
god i need this i need this super soaker
look it's
it pumps out ten thousand of what uh
whatever the advertisers you know
they're just like please please please
and i look at them and i could just see
the craving all over their face
just this sort of innocent like but but
what do i know i know
that within three hours of getting that
thing it's just gonna be tossed on the
pile of all their other discarded things
and so i look at them and i mean i
quietly kind of judge them i'm like
oh you simpleton
but then five minutes later i'm on
youtube
watching a commercial about i don't know
it's some
it is the targeted marketing is getting
quite remarkable i like used to like
when i watch television i
almost care about next to nothing on
but like the internet like they're they
know me they got my profile facebook's
got my profile and i mean whatever it is
like
right when i want blue bell suddenly
blue bell ice cream advertisements and i
look at i'm like
yes yes that that is the key
that would make me so happy um forever
here's i have a few examples here's a
ridiculous advertisement this is from
mcdonald's
uh scott you put that up it says crafted
for your craving
for those listening like via podcast
later it's basically it's a picture
of a beautiful hamburger and i mean it
really is lovely
isn't it sad like it never looks like
that when you buy it does it never
uh crafted for your craving what's the
what's the message here
uh the message is if you crave
something go for it
you deserve it i mean have you had your
break today
probably not like so go for it and
then you'll be happy this is life it's
desire and it's satisfying the desires
uh or here's one this is not
um food related so much uh it says
don't let desire pass you by
and again for those listening via
podcasts later it's a
it's an image of two very beautiful
people
uh and they are about to kiss and the
subtitle
um it's it's probably small on your
screen but uh it says
seduction infatuation
tragic love give in to the epic romance
of
opera at the net i guess is the new york
metropolitan opera that's my guess
um and i mean just it's i mean it's
strange like seeing it kind of with a
certain remove you know it just sounds
utterly ridiculous and yet something in
us
kind of starts to get drunk yeah that's
my ticket to happiness
uh why why is this what's going on i
mean it's ephesians 2.
it's it's just the way of the world
craving
and aversion aversion and craving
and that's why paul says all of us lived
among
them at one time we have all been there
and maybe we still are there drinking
salt water
in an effort to satisfy our thirst
but if you call yourself a follower of
christ then you are on a journey
it's a journey as we talked about a few
weeks ago into
transfiguration this deep
transformation um into
um christ's likeness in end
where basically where every cell of your
body
radiates the divine life this is why
paul in verse 3 um says oh oh yes
that that used to be us we were we were
those people we were chasing our
cravings
but then he goes on in verse 4 to say
but because
of his great love for us
god who is rich in mercy
made us alive with christ
even when we were dead in
transgressions in other words in our
sins it is by
grace you have been saved
what he's getting at is he's naming that
god
through the life death and resurrection
of jesus and through the sending of the
holy spirit
is now luring us
calling us drawing and
transforming us into christ's image
and and notice the closing statement
there it is by grace
you have been saved which is to say this
is a mysterious
work of god in you god
is doing the transforming and
this brings me back to the passage we
read previously
from isaiah chapter 30 verse 15.
this is what the sovereign lord the holy
one of israel says
only in returning to me
and resting in me will you
be saved in quietness
and confidence is your strength
oh but you would have none of it in
other words this is not
some elaborate um
formula of spiritual transformation this
is not some
complex series of religious hoops
to jump through just so like
no this is the grace of god which means
if we have really any work to do any
part to play at
all it's it's simply the work of
surrender uh of trust
of what isaiah 30 calls return
returning to his presence
only in returning to me isaiah writes
resting in me will you be
saved uh i'm big on the dog analogies
tonight so i was i was thinking earlier
it's sort of like um
when you're trying to give your dog a
bath in the tub
and uh they keep jumping out
right they're just like pawing that
they're like flying me out of here and i
mean honestly they don't have to do
anything
except stand there like then they would
be cleaned then
because you're going to do all the work
like you're i have a little
little handle spray thing which is very
helpful all dog owners need some
attachment like this
and i'm like oh my gosh dog just all you
have to do
is stand there i am going to literally
like
spray massage in you know the bubble i'm
going to do it all
but my dog won't he just keeps he's
trying right and that's us
god is doing all the hard work we
just have to stay put um
but boy do we struggle to stay put i
mean like like hawkinsmith said we
we just run um let me kind of
let me reframe it and recap um recap it
like this
uh to summarize craving in other words
craving
is chasing craving is chasing it's
chasing pleasure
it's chasing a peace that never lasts
it's it's a
chasing that really at its root it's an
avoiding
of the present moment um and that's
basically what ephesians 2
is i think getting at but christian
spirituality
is returning it's re it's a return
returning
to god returning to myself
returning to the present moment the
place
where god's presence is happening
in me and that of course that's isaiah
30.
um as the 12th century christian mystic
meister eckhart says god
is at home it is we who have gone
out for a walk god is at home it is we
who have gone out
for a walk what he's saying is god is at
home within
christ is within you the kingdom of god
is is through the holy spirit is within
you
right the reality of god is happening in
you but but what happens we keep
we keep leaving ourselves so to speak
right you keep believing you you keep
running we keep um jumping out of the
tub
um one word that's that's often used
that i actually think i think it's
really helpful it's a helpful
metaphor of this idea of returning
um and it's the word centered
uh and karen actually used it earlier
tonight
um this this idea of being being
centered remaining centered which can
sound a little i get it like a little
buzzwordish
um but it's really i think it's really
really helpful
um and i think the reason it's helpful
is because it's a word that describes
um the the feeling on the inside
of as eckhart says of being at home
with god with ourselves being okay
with who we are and our life
as it actually is
right now uh and so let me kind of
describe let me describe that that
feeling centered uh you know you know
when you're like when you're in that
state
where you are very energized right like
you're not sleepy
um and yet you're calm so it's kind of
an alertness and yet you're calm
that um that inner state where praise
the lord
your mind is not obsessing about the
past or running
wildly off into the future in that crazy
anxious way it usually does
but instead you are simply here
present and and you find
that in that place you are at
your absolute best it's
it's like you're this ego
um part of you this false self part of
you it is
dropping away and your true self
that is your god-centered holy spirit
infused self
is able to make the perfect response
and when you're kind of in that zone so
to speak um
even just your presence can become
healing and life-giving for the people
around you
like you don't even have to do anything
you can just be there
listening and it's like
god is it something is happening um
now what's going on why is this is it
because like we're so great and
spiritual um i don't think so
no i think it's because god um in this
time we are allowing the holy spirit to
flow through
us right we are centered we we are
present
in that time we don't need to return
because we are already home
if you uh if you can't tell i'm speaking
now very much from experience um this
is really this is my own journey of
trying to live into ephesians 2 in
isaiah
30 because um when i parent
just for example from that place of
restlessness that anxiety
and and either craving or aversion
uh it's a it's a disaster
when when i relate to my wife maggie
from that place of restlessness anxiety
craving a version it's
it's a disaster uh
and i had to say it when i pastor
whether it's
it's you know counseling with someone or
i'm just maybe in a meeting
or god forbid i'm trying to resolve
conflict
and i'm operating from a place of
of craving or aversion uh some some
place of like
i'm kind of needing to control like they
better listen to me um they better
change they
they better not say such and such they
they better they better do this and not
that they better say this and not that
they better not do that thing i hate
like oh yeah it's like i mean at its
worst like how did the the apostle paul
put as
as brock ellison read earlier um the
quote from paul is the it's like the
the ruler of the kingdom of the air
that was the language just sort of this
demonic like some dark spirit
uh some terrible shadow is using me when
i get in that mode
like oh lord have mercy but
the moment i return
the moment i return the moment i take a
deep breath
and i return to god in my true self
suddenly man god is so faithful it's
like the spirit is flowing through me
again why because it is always in a
sense
of inner quietness in peace
that we find god that's our work it's
the
work of return so
um in closing i'd like to get very
practical
and answer on the question you might be
wondering
uh which is you know like how do i
return
um and let me start by saying
you know again there is no like secret
formula
as ephesians 2 and isaiah 30 name very
really clearly this is a work of god
there's a there's the gracious goodness
of god in us that does this and so
honestly
i do not know how
spiritual transformation happens exactly
i don't know i don't get it um but what
i can encourage you to do
is engage um the same
kind of paths of return we call them
around here spiritual disciplines
or spiritual practices um that
basically it's the same um practices
that people
on this christian path have been
practicing now for you know
um a few thousand years so um let me
mention just a few examples from people
here
um at the table um one practice is
journaling
journaling um my wife maggie she is a
journaler this is her thing
and if you think about it like it's
pretty it's really i think a smart
practice because she kind of lives her
day
and then she reflects on her day
right where where was she in tune with
god
i'm living in her true self and where
was she
not so much and and then it's in the
process of
writing that she becomes more discerning
of these kind of two states of being
right she and so she's growing in
self-awareness she's growing in
um in her god awareness so journaling is
one path
um second worship through music
i suspect this is adam thompson's
path adam uh will occasionally send me
songs or like screenshots of songs
and he'll say things like oh man this
song has been bringing me to god
and which i'm always very encouraged by
to know people
you know learning to love god and
actually doing that like outside of
sundays
does my pastor's heart good um but also
adam he loves playing music
right so it's not just listening but
it's playing and so i just
my hunches this is one of adam's uh
paths
and there is uh something about
music isn't there where just where we're
really paying attention
um that for many people when we're doing
that it just it brings us
back to god's presence
it's a powerful powerful form of return
the third third way is scripture this is
folks like
um roy parker i know stephanie acuna
does this
quite a bit um graeme branson and
honestly anyone
you know who wants to be shaped by
christ in the christian story i mean you
just cannot get around like scripture
it's just
really essential um and there's
something you know about
uh not even necessarily like mining it
for like
nuggets or something but just reading it
slowly and
and kind of prayerfully meditatively
just allowing god
to highlight things to bring them to
your attention i think it really infuses
um the mind with with god's story and
and again it's a great way um to grow in
self-awareness and god awareness and
then finally
um prayer prayer and meditation
uh you know folks like josh brock and
myself we we really love prayer
and specifically the prayer of silence
and as i told you before i practice
something called centering prayer you
can google it
and um i like it because i feel like
it's such a direct
practice of return you know i'm just i'm
sitting in god's presence i'm there
i'm silent and then what happens my mind
starts to wander and at times it's sort
of you know
just normal silly stuff kind of just
distraction
and then other times it's you know back
to like ruler of the kingdom of the air
kind of stuff like it's my
my mind you know really dark places fury
and rage at someone
and it's just this beautiful practice of
like okay no
just returning just returning to god's
presence again
and again and again and that's a
wonderful practice
um for life and of course i mean there
are others i could talk about
um fasting i could talk about um
community you know
meetups and sharing that's so powerful
to
because when you're in community people
reflect back to you they become
sort of a conduit for god to meet you so
i mean i go on and on this is not some
exhaustive list
um but i hope my hope and prayer is that
in the season of lent
you're able to intentionally engage
something right it's very easy to get
quite
um judgy of other christians come on man
why don't those christians act like true
christians they're so unconscious they
they totally lack self-awareness
um all while completely failing to do
any practice
that would open us up to god's presence
so let's uh in this season let's not
just talk about it let's not just blame
others for their own failures to return
uh let's live it let's live it ourselves
let me pray for you lord jesus i
thank you for this community and i thank
you that you are teaching us
to return and so that i pray for
perseverance
and faithfulness god even if it's even
if it's ten thousand
times a day would we return
god through music through art
through prayer and scripture and
community
god would we return would we learn to
live from our true
selves and from that place god set us
free set us free i just pray for every
person
who resonated with that opening story
and and
quote god either lost in
in addiction in just a restlessness
lord would you meet them powerfully
do a deep work in their hearts
yeah save us god save us from ourselves
do your work in the name of jesus i pray
amen
you're in the place you think
[Music]
you have a place to rest
your head but not all
feels like you've lost yourself
again sitting in the silence
[Music]
you choose to bear
keeping yourselves from those who
care problems and pride play hide
and seek you're unaware
[Music]
a picture of ourselves that is
know
[Music]
do you ever
so
in time
[Music]
may you find
feels like you've lost yourself
again sitting in the silence of
a friend when you are fully
known and loved you
[Music]
a friend when you are fully
known
[Music]
whoever
peace of mind
[Music]
thanks gary that was beautiful i love
that song
i was chuckling a little bit because it
was a little bit of a magic trick we're
like in the exact same spot
we just traded really really fast we're
good like that
um thank you so much for being with us
tonight i hope
that the music and the prayers
and the message and the community uh
blessed you
and reminded you that you are not alone
and
this is a community where uh our heart
is for you
to be fully known and fully loved just
as you
are um and it's hard to do that in
isolation
so if there is anything that we can help
you with
tangibly or just as a listening ear
or a prayer we want to
be that for you we want to be that to
one another
so please send us an email
put a message in the comments and we
will make sure to connect with you
also if you resonate with our vision
and our values and with what we're doing
here at the table
i would love for you to consider
a financial gift to us you can do that
online on our website
at thetabletx.org
i know things have been tough with
quarantine and with covid
it's hit everybody's budget but if
there is any extra we would love for
your
um for you to consider donating to the
table so that we can continue this work
that we feel
that god has called us to um
also i wanted to remind you that next
saturday
uh our book club is going to be meeting
at 10 a.m
and we are reading the book cast
by isabel wilkerson it is phenomenal
it's so so good um so if you haven't
picked up the book yet there's still
time to do that
also it's you know it's it's a fairly
big book and so what we're doing
is we're taking it in chunks and so this
coming saturday we're just going to be
discussing parts one through three
so you don't have to read it all in one
fell swoop
and you will have several months to read
this book so
i would love for you to be a part of it
it's going to be a great discussion
and if you'd like more information on
the meeting next saturday
you can fill out the meetup form that
marissa's going to post in the comments
below
so as you head into your week let me
leave you with this benediction
you are a child of god this is true
on your best days and on your worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only
one you nothing about you is a mistake
and this world needs you being fully
yourself
authentic and free so as you go into the
week ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are accepted
and you are worthy just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
i hope you have a great week and i hope
to see you back here next sunday
bye
you